[Musique]
c'est assez surprenant que ce symbole là
soit aussi répandue en russie parce que
la lettre z n'existe pas dans l'alphabet
cyrillique donc l'alphabet russe est
plutôt lettres latines mais plusieurs
définitions de ce que veut dire que ces
deux là mais ce qu'on voit surtout dans
les comptes gouvernementaux
c'est des mots clés qui commence par ça
avec un grand s dôngs à qui veut dire
pour en russe donc on voit des mots clés
tels que ja la paix à notre nos troupes
à la victoire à la justice donc vraiment
un message en faveur de cette
intervention militaire russe et qui sont
la russie bon c'est une opération de
paix une version de libération de
l'ukraine paie finalement c'est utilisée
par des sources proches du gouvernement
comme les publications de voyelles écran
département de la défense en russie pour
soutenir le message gouvernemental et
soutenir là
c'est difficile de savoir à quel point
que la population est derrière ça c'est
sûr que des sondages cette semaine qui
disait quand même que 60 % environ de la
russie est en faveur de l'intervention
militaire en ukraine
mais cela dit de savoir à quel point
s'est répandue dans les rues ça c'est
difficile parce que les médias
indépendants en russie aux russes y ont
été fermés la semaine dernière beaucoup
des médias étrangers
ne sont plus le non plus à cause de
cette nouvelle loi qui interdit la
diffusion d'informations qui selon le
kremlin sont mensongères certain qu'il
ya des citoyens wiki de leur propre chef
mettre des aides sur la voiture portent
des t-shirts du z mais les experts qui
disent attention ça se peut qu'on a
affaire ici à une campagne des dations
que le film du gouvernement russe astro
talking notre ancien qui se traduit par
ci militantisme c'est quand des
organisations parfois des fins
commerciales mais dans ce cas-ci
politiques
amplifie faussement un mouvement qui
serait
citoyens en apparence on pense que s'il
ya l'historien ian gordon qui se
spécialise en propagande russe avec qui
j'ai parlé
qui dit qu'il ya beaucoup de ces
rassemblements la russie qui ont l'air
spontanée mais qui finalement quand on
creuse 100 m organisé par
par le kremlin par exemple cette photo
ici de vie us dans les rues
monsieur vendeurs se pose la question
comment se fait-il que il ya une flotte
de vue est noir identique avec des hyper
long drapeau russe et ces versements qui
ont aussi des lettres z dessus qui
aurait accès à ce genre de flottes de
véhicules autres que des agents
gouvernementaux
sinon il ya d'autres rassemblements
convoi en russie qui semble spontanée où
on voit des étudiants qui se rassemblent
et d'échanger avec des aides dessus ici
c'est des images du centre d'achat dans
la ville de kazan qui ont circulé ce
qu'on a appris finalement c'est que les
étudiants dans ces images là on était
obligé à participer à ce rassemblement
par l'université de kazan donc ça semble
spontanée s'assemblent organiques alors
qu'en réalité tout ça est organisée par
les autorités en russie finalement est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de
soutien au sénat population pour cette
campagne z non il ya visiblement du vrai
soutien ça se peut aussi que çà çà çà çà
prennent une ampleur inédite dans les
prochaines semaines et que des
mouvements deviennent immense mais pour
l'instant il semble que beaucoup de ça
est soutenu par l'état même s'il est à
10 noeuds ne pas nécessairement avoir de
lien avec cette campagne en z là mais ce
que m'a dit aussi monsieur green earth
et cultivant dans un pays comme la
russie ou la dissension et de plus en
plus
puni ou les gens qui manifestent dans la
rue peuvent se faire jeter en prison
mais l'opinion publique n'est plus temps
importante quand le gouvernement
contrôle autant le message